up next is going to be Ryan in Houston
Texas hey Ryan how are you mr. Ramsey
I'm doing great in yourself better than
I deserve what's up
thank you for taking my call um man I've
been meaning to call and ask question
for a while now uh I'm in alpha been in
for about seven and a half years I'm
married and my mortgage payments a
little outside what you'd recommend I
just wanted to get your advice on
whether I should stay Pat and you know
anticipate or you know make a move for
more
um what's more by yeah it's more of a
guideline to keep you from being house
poor you know I mean I have people call
me up their house payments 50% of their
take-home pay and they wonder why they
can't breathe you know that's why you
know but you know we tell people 25% of
your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed if
you're a twenty six point five or you're
going to go broke no it's a guideline
you know it's a general idea don't be
broke because of your house so how much
is your house payment fifteen hundred
and your take-home pay is about 950 a
week 950 a week and so we're talking
about somewhere in the four thousand
dollar range average and yeah that's
pretty steep you know you you know
you're up over 30 something percent so
if you got any other debt I we owe
$2,000 to Social Security
my wife is blind and when and they've
got her set up you know after she
married me and so we owe them yeah fat
and the is the trend on your income
heading up a pretty steep or is it going
to be just like cost living raises uh I
think it's headed up pretty good
assuming I keep my act together yeah I
mean like if you're in sales or you got
a bonus program or something like that
then you can kind of see the light the
point is you don't want to wake up five
years from now and still be sitting
there because you're going to trouble
saving for other stuff right for save up
for the next car I mean you that that's
a big bite but if you're heading out of
the woods
then you know I sell a house very slowly
I'll sell your car in about 30 seconds
but your house is it's an emotional
attacks on your family to move and it's
very expensive to move and you know
takes up a lot of time and productivity
and that you would have been doing other
stuff with the move and so I only move
if we have to so if I thought you were
going to be stuck there for five years
you say you know I'm a government worker
I'm gonna get a 2% raise a year you
probably be moving it probably a good
idea but if you could see yourself
trending up to where this is going to
end up being you know 25% or 30% or that
kind of a thing so $4,500 would be 33%
right mm-hmm is where you'd be at
one-third then and you're not that far
from that so you're not you know you're
not dying in here it's just a matter of
if you can see yourself trending out of
it and you like the house and I would
stay in the house okay so I need to
trend up to about when I'm a guest by
your recommendation about six grand I'm
in the next couple of years real quick
yeah and it sounds like you kind of
think you're heading that way yeah best
laid plans oh yeah yeah I mean it's
always a it's always fits the starts it
never is a straight line the success
thing but but you know the good news is
is you're not like capped or locked in
it sounds like you've got a situation
where you have some control over your
destiny which is what you want to do so
yeah I think you're fine it long-term
short-term you should be feeling a pinch
because it's a little high a little high
amen thanks for the call hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you're enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right kind of better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you